the ultimate goal is to create an image
that
gives emotion to my client and to myself
if somebody writes me and wants like a
scarface sleeve
and they got you know 100 grand well i'm
not going to say i'm not going to do it
but
i'm not gonna do something that my soul
isn't in what's up gq
um snuffy we're gonna be looking at some
of my tattoos
i love machine gun kelly he's one of the
hardest working people i know
and um inspiration of mine i've actually
done quite a bit of tattoos on him but
they're all in like hidden places back
of the legs and stuff
because he's already covered he's always
got his shirt off and stuff the first
piece i did for machine and kelly you
have
one boy who's boxing and then you have
i think it's joe dimaggio with the life
on his head
like super ironic just like slap in the
face
kind of imagery you fight really hard in
life in a certain direction but life's
got its own plans
the way my process is everyone has to
write me a story
i reread that story and sort of like dj
a bunch of images together
until it makes me feel something in
order to create
timeless pieces i pull images from
pre-1970
all the time the focus isn't the fashion
it's more about
the motion or the action of the person
with regards to the life piece
is what we call a sticker tattoo so it
can kind of just get slapped anywhere
it doesn't really fit the contours of
the body the greatest challenge with
that piece
was i think i got to his house around
12 and he had to be
on the floor seat of the lakers game by
5 30.
so i only had like three hours or
something to actually tattoo
no piece of art is ever really done so i
could have
spent five hours or six hours doing it
but yeah
i was on on power mode that time
with regards to the blindfold tattoo
that i did on the back of his leg that
one
more so fits the contour of his body the
piece like funnels
down to kind of match the shape of the
leg
the piece is meant to represent all the
yes people
in los angeles and anyone that knows
houdini knows that
he didn't die in that trick despite all
of the people who
were kind of fake you know he still
managed to make it to the top
and now he's got number one album
instead of putting
kind of a clasp or something that's
going to hold the chain i really thought
it would kind of take away
from the two important pieces which is
the humans on top and
houdini on the bottom the way i describe
my work is black and gray surrealism
the fun part about creating surrealism
is that doesn't need something to hold
it there there's no gravity
on the tattoo the idea is to just convey
a message
however possible
with the hotel diablo tattoo on the back
of kel's head we were in the studio and
it was like
early hours of the morning just talking
about
what the album means each song was kind
of
a room inside of the hotel and the whole
hotel was
his brain so the entrance to the hotel
was
his head we did the hotel diablo logo on
the back of his head
and then it just like all kind of made
sense he was like let's do it when they
were doing the the cover shoot
and then justin campbell was a great
photographer
took some amazing photos probably
five minutes after i tattooed himself
and then actually kel's
tattooed that logo on me i had him
tattoo it on my leg
the other piece kel's was here in new
york
shooting his scenes in uh king of staten
island pete's movie
yeah i got a call to come over to
pete davidson's house he's like yo i
really need you to tattoo the back of my
neck
it was like first time i ever met pete
and i'm just like tattooing kel's
yeah his mom was like cooking food and
it was like you know three in the
morning
i actually was pretty mad because that
was a piece that i really wanted on
myself
it just represents this like struggle
within like
we're in our own jail i've done a load
of tattoos on pete like an
astronomical amount of tattoos on him um
they're just all like tucked away and
you know they're just not uh advertised
a few months
subsequent to tattooing kells at pete's
house
i was in sweden and i get a text yo
this is pete davidson can you come
tattoo me tomorrow
i came up with this piece for the back
of his shoulder
which is mostly line work it's pretty
much
uh spears with the the heads of like
dead idols which are cartoon characters
so i flew back from sweden
came back to brooklyn grabbed my head
straight from the airport
went to his crib and tattooed him till
nine in the morning
i don't like to do that man it's like
very exhausting
tattooing when you're tired is really
kind of like not such a bad thing
because
you're too tired to think about anything
else you're just like sick that's what
i'm doing
kind of calm really light hand make sure
that i stencil
as well as i can i study the design that
i created so that
i don't have to think too much while i'm
doing it the second i pick up the
machine
i don't look at my phone i'm busy
and the only thing i'm doing is focusing
on a piece of skin from six inches away
and
it's very therapeutic
the leg tattoo i did on pete oh
i love that tattoo he wanted
a tribute to all of his comedy gods
so instead of going with that classic
face on top of face on top of face on
top of face and covering the thing i
try to use a lot of negative space and
it puts
the attention on the tattoo instead of
just like covering the whole skin
so i hung them in picture frames around
his leg
first thing i did was i sharpied the
chains on him to see where to place the
frames
once the sharpie was on there then i put
the frames on him
and then i took the faces and put them
inside the frames
well excuse you
what makes a good portrait is the whole
technical application
it's really just like this human's face
that you have to sculpt i think the most
difficult thing is
achieving like perfect gradient shading
or having a tattoo with multiple
different textures
i think that's actually way more
difficult than pulling a straight line
at this point it's just muscle memory in
the sense
this is where i have to start this is
where i have to end and i just knock
that
out and move on there's many different
needle groupings i use
primarily uh liners or mags
well the smallest one is a single one so
it's just one needle
but then you have like a three which is
the next like
grouping up which you basically have
three needles
grouped in a triangle and then it goes
in
odd numbers in this same grouping shape
with a tight three i can achieve what
pretty much
looks like a single needle tattoo the
reason i like to use the three is
because
the ink sits in between the three
needles
inside this thing and travels down
and that doesn't occur with a single
needle the single needle the ink comes
around it so sometimes it doesn't
actually
come out and then you're just like
tattooing a needle and then
it's just blood and then the five
magnum is what i like to use for shading
the magnum is the shape
and the number five is how many needles
griffin glock tattoo was hilarious pete
flew us all out to the taping of his
special
we get on the plane and i'm like yo
griff i'm gonna tattoo you on this
airplane and he's like word let's do it
so like i've scoped in the area i'll
make sure that this
like the stewards and this the flight
attendants are
not paying attention and i'm just like
shake up the ink bottle i'm like talking
to griffin
like ready to go um like all right word
so we're just i'm just gonna
freestyle it and i'm looking at him i
opened the ink bottle
i didn't realize the pressurized cabin
the ink just sprays all over my face
in coach i'm like oh so i got ink all
over me and everything so i'm like wipe
off
like whatever wipe it still got some on
my face i'm like here give me your arm
put his arm on the table and i just did
like a little smiley face on him
and that was it tattooed griffin gluck
and coach
on a commercial flight there's a huge
difference
tattooing out in the world outside of my
own studio
because i have to like bring my mobile
like setup with me i'm used to it and i
just like
really like pared it down to like a very
clean
setup there are many tattoo machines
there's basically coil machines which
are those loud ones
and then there's rotary machines which
are these which are the quieter ones
the rotary machines have a motor that
goes
in a circle and then you have the needle
bar
which goes on this nub and this thing
kind of like
there's a circle and then this goes back
the first machine i ever used is the
bishop rotary v6
it's an amazing machine shout out to
franco
the guy made some amazing amazing stuff
he's also a great tattooer
this machine is called a
dragonfly now this power supply
when you go fast the needle's entering
the skin
more times and when you go slow it
enters the skin less times
this machine i can adjust how
much give when i spin this the needle
will
be kind of like a little bit bouncier on
the skin
so i can really go a little bit like
softer when i tattoo
athletes and when i tattoo really
muscular people
i like to make the machine softer and i
like to run a little bit slower
but the machine that i've been using the
most is
the zion fk irons i can adjust the
settings on this as well hard and soft
same thing i think i tattooed like damn
near all the people we talked about with
this machine right here
ah bad boy that was a super fun tattoo
we just pulled up to chill like it
wasn't even for we didn't
like i was not intending to tattoo him
at all we
went to get some food around the corner
then he had just got
a diamond tennis bracelet he looked down
at his wrist and
it was gone from the time we were here
ate food and came back he had lost his
tennis bracelet so i was like
i'll give you something that you can't
lose so i made this tattoo for him and
he's a really big like charity dude
at the time we were discussing like the
rhinos going extinct
i did a little bit of stippling
which is what the dot work would be
called on it it's a skill in itself
there's people who do really light
flowers
and on the petals they'll create
shape by lowering the machine and moving
the hand
pretty fast and it creates dots that go
right in
in a line in the direction because the
hand is
always being used you're always washing
your hands it's
always in the sun the tattoos tend to
fade that's life i've seen people with
really thin lines and it's
been there for 10 years and i've seen
people with thin lines that have
disappeared but that's the wabi-sabi
thing it's like there's character in
things that are [ __ ] up
ah hannah cider for the kids it's an old
school
um phone like a pay phone and it's just
off the hook
like you know can't reach me that that
tattoo is pretty much
uh just having to do with society being
glued to the phone hannah loves that
tattoo but she always likes to go
hello hello every time so
i'm just an empty vehicle and my
client's story is the fuel for that
vehicle
so ultimately comes both of our stories
is me identifying with my client
putting myself in their shoes creating a
story from that
and people are coming in here and and
really it's a therapy
session for both of us every time a
recent one that i did
is like an arc with the eyeballs inside
the arcs
and they're all crying and all the
water's running through the mouth
into a bucket with holes in it and
that's a recent tattoo that i'm
absolutely in love with i adore that
tattoo
but it's a very powerful tattoo that's
attached to a very powerful story
this person had trouble being alive
it's kind of saying that
everyone's watching but no one's
listening this one is a
is one that has to do with battling
addiction it seems like it's all under
control but the ground's falling out
beneath them
he's got a monkey on his back the monkey
seems to be juggling
pretty well but he's cheating because
glued to the
sticks and you got the addiction
creeping up behind the monkey
i'm coming up on 10 years of sobriety so
i identified with this story
quite well this is more of a heritage
piece her mother passed away
from a lung disease if i recall
correctly yeah i thought it was really
beautiful you have
the woman who's walking forward
which is the client who's continuing in
life
without forgetting this is one of my
all-time favorite tattoos because it's
simple tattoo that covers a large area
you have a person at the bottom who's
reaching for help and then you have a
bunch of people up top
that are offering their help people on
the top are all
reaching down and they have keys hanging
off because the person on the bottom is
in handcuffs the person in the bottom
is asking for help but doesn't realize
that there's a key hanging off their own
hand
[Music]
being a tattooer has required me to
learn how to
uh take photographs be a therapist
shave men you know be personable be
on you know and create a [ __ ] piece
that's gonna sit on your body forever
that means something
and then execute it it's a lot
so it takes a lot of energy the longer i
do it the more of a challenge it becomes
because i'm kind of like using up ideas
you know after i do a tattoo that i'm
immensely proud of i'm like i uh
i think i'm done like you know it's like
there's nothing left you know
but somehow someway more stuff comes and
then i make
other things that i'm also proud of and
then goes out into the world